What is up, people?
In this video,
we're going to look at the factors that increase demand.
So the first factor is an increasing price
of a substitute good.
Second factor is a decrease in price
of a complimentary good.
The third factor is a changing consumer preferences.
Um, the benefit is good. Um,
the fourth factor is a changing expected future prices,
where people think they
will be more expensive in the future.
The next factor, um,
is an increase in income for normal goods.
However, it is the opposite for inferior goods,
where a decrease in income
leads to an increase in demand.
And essentially,
an inferior good is the same as a necessity.
So, hope you enjoyed the video, guys.